For a long, long time I didn’t know what
was happening to the cows and the chickens
and the dairy and egg industry.
So once I learned that they forcibly impregnate
the cows, take their babies away, kill the
bulls, exploit the mothers for five years
until they kill them, grinding up male chickens…so
there’s a lot of injustice in there.
So once I learned that, I said okay I am a
hypocrite saying I love animals but still
consuming those products.
So that’s when I went vegan four years ago.
We show videos from the international animal
agriculture.
Doesn’t matter if its organic or factory
farming because it’s always an animal.
These are videos from all over the world,
even from Germany.
So regularly we just let the people see or
watch the documentaries for 30 seconds, then
we speak to them and we ask them questions,
to really think about it, to take a breath
and maybe then talk.
Because these are very hard documentaries,
and no one wants to see it but everyone wants
to eat it.
You aren’t going to talk to someone who
never thought about veganism and get them
vegan in a second.
You are just going to plant a seed and then
the next person or the next video they see,
will put a bit of water on that seed and at
the end, the plant of veganism grows.
So we can be the last person that talks to
them that makes them go vegan, or the first
view of animal killings that they see in their
lives.
Some people might criticize that we are hiding
ourselves behind the mask, but the concept
is, first, the meaning of V for Vendetta,
which is about uncovering injustices and fighting
against it.
The second reason is that when you go up to
a cube of truth and watch the videos, it’s
better for you not to feel observed.
So when someone is wearing the mask, you don’t
feel like he is judging me or gauging my facial
reactions so it makes it easier for people
to watch the videos.
I just came from there and I saw them all
wearing these masks.
First of all it’s cool, it absolutely attracted
my attention.
I just had a really nice conversation with
that dude there, we talked about is that really
human to kill animals and we shared our different
opinions.
I think it’s good because normally when
you are working in your normal life you don’t
think about these questions that often, or
that deep.
Because eating meat for us is too normal.
The question I always ask at the beginning
is: What do you think?
What are your feelings about that?”
And I always specify that there is no right
or wrong answer to that question.
And then I always say, “Ok so are you against
animal cruelty or do you not like that people
harm the animals?”
And everyone says, “No I do not like that.”
And then I say, “But do you pay every day
for the people that do that?”
And they say, “Yes, that’s a point.”
And I’m saying like yeah, it’s not about
judging people.
It’s just about making them realize and
connect the fact that they are paying for
people to do what they don’t like to see
the people do.
She told us about the vegans, the violence
against animals, and the torture and the big
animal factories.
We could make an idea about all this.
And we had a small talk about to be vegan
for one week.
I am not vegan now, so I’ll try it for one
week and yeah.
Being vegan on my own wasn’t enough for
me.
Because I realized that it’s a good step
to do something yourself, but I want to spread
information to more people in a nice way.
Not getting angry or so.
Sometimes in my own environment people get
kind of aggressive when you tell them you’re
vegan, and they get a bad conscious.
Here it is a good way to get positive information
and to spread something which is maybe contributing
to a better world.